[inaudible] been definitely towards
canal.
Good evening folks.
Today I want to talk about uh,
studying Japanese and the most useful
materials for learning Japanese.
Obviously I haven't used all the
different materials in the world for
studying Japanese,
but I have to do some and that's
familiar with others to some extent.
So I'll tell you about what I think and
my experience.
One of the good things about studying
Japanese is that there is such a wide
range of good materials.
Uh,
there's just,
there's a lot out there to choose from.
So you can go to the bookstore and look
through a bunch of books and see which
ones appeal to you.
Uh,
it comes down to learning style and
taste to some extent,
but I'll just get into it.
Uh,
the first series that I used was called
Japanese for busy people.
So there are,
uh,
well the title was always kind of funny.
I don't know why it's for busy people.
Why not for business people?
The content of this series is basically
for business.
It's for simple business situations
where like do you go on a business trip
to Tokyo when you talked to like a,
what was it,
uh,
Mr Tanaka from Tokyo Electric and that
kind of thing.
So the situations are kind of business.
I found that aspect of it a little
boring because I was never working in
business in Japan.
I came here as a teacher,
um,
so that it might not be relevant for you
in terms of content and completely,
but it's a good series and if you go
through volumes one,
two and maybe three,
you'll learn quite a bit.
Uh,
it's quite well laid out.
it has like a short conversation in each
chapter.
Then it introduces the vocabulary and
some grammar from,
uh,
from that conversation and gives you
some exercises to practice it.
And it's quite,
quite good,
useful,
standard Japanese.
And I think it's a good series.
Um,
there's another popular series called,
uh,
it's called [inaudible] or a Japanese
for every one.
And that one is quite good as well.
I haven't used the whole thing,
but I've looked through it and it looks
quite good.
And a lot of people swear by it.
So that's another one to think about is,
I mean Danone Hong Kong or Japanese for
everyone as it's called.
Another series I used was one that's
only published in Vancouver.
It's published at a Japanese language
school in Vancouver,
I think it's called Nakagawa language
center and it's called gum bucket.
That's the name of the series.
And that one was really good.
It was really fun.
It was really motivating.
I really liked that.
The best as a like a pure beginners
textbook or five volumes,
five volumes.
Um,
number one is really simple,
but it goes up to five and if you finish
up to volume five,
that prepares you for the first level of
the Japanese proficiency test.
Uh,
but all the conversations and the
characters and stuff were quite cute and
I'm quite motivating.
They got me interested in learning
Japanese more.
Let me just double check the name of
that center.
No,
not knock a Gullah,
sorry to Nina Ogawa Japanese language.
So it's hard to get those books.
I don't know if you can find the
[inaudible] gum but day series,
but if you can find it online,
I think you can order it through the
website of new gala.com.
So have a look if you can get it.
It's good for beginners,
at least the lower levels.
So those were the beginning textbooks at
an intermediate level.
I loved this book,
this one and integrated approach to
intermediate Japanese by a Kiddo Muda.
And now when we Hanukkah mcgloin,
this one was awesome.
This made me really love studying
Japanese.
Uh,
the way it was laid out.
The conversations were fun and
interesting.
The stories and texts were interesting
and it wasn't focused on business.
It was focused on college life.
And I wasn't a student,
but I had been a student so I could
relate to college life a little bit
better than corporate life.
So the vocab and the topics and just the
whole theme of this book was more
interesting to me.
Some people don't seem to like it.
I've read some of the reviews on Amazon
and some people say they find it hard to
follow.
Um,
it might depend on your learning style.
Like I'm a very inductive learner.
I like to look at texts and
conversations and kind of figure out
what's going on and look at the pieces.
And God,
this piece must be the verb.
This must be the whatever.
I like to figure things out.
Um,
and that works well with this book
because it's the beginning of each
chapter and it will have like,
uh,
like two or three different
conversations or texts.
So if we look at this one,
it's got one conversation,
then it's got another one,
and then after that it's got a text.
And then after that it has the
vocabulary.
And after the vocabulary,
then it has,
uh,
that's the congee.
Then after that it has the grammar
points and then it has a grammar
exercises.
So the,
the texts and the conversations are
separate from all of the breakdown and
the explanation and the exercises.
Those come after the texts.
So for me,
that's fine.
I like to look at the text and the
conversations and then flip back to the
explanations when I need it.
And then I can figure out the other
things on my own to whatever extent I
can.
Then I can just flip back if I need an
explanation.
Some people like to have the explanation
right up front in their face from the
beginning.
They're more deductive learners.
Uh,
they like to have it explained to them
before they read the text or at the same
time.
So if you are like that,
you might not like this book that much,
but have a look at it.
I really liked it and this was my
favorite book ever.
So another one at the intermediate level
was this one,
which I didn't like.
I didn't have as much fun with it,
but it was useful.
It taught me a lot.
It's this one,
uh,
[inaudible],
that means Japanese from the
intermediate level.
That's the name,
that's the meaning of this title.
But this one is completely in Japanese.
This other one and integrated approach.
The one I showed you before,
this has a lot of English in it and has
translations and explanations.
This one is all in Japanese.
So this one is a bit more,
uh,
intense of an experience because you
have to dive right in.
It's all Japanese,
no explanations.
It doesn't even have a title in English.
When I looked this up on Amazon to check
if it's available,
uh,
I had,
I had to type in the espn number because
when I typed in the Japanese,
it didn't show up because it was
amazon.com
in America.
But,
uh,
if I looked up the espn,
then this name,
this title appeared in Roman characters
in Amazon.
So it doesn't even have an English name.
You would have to look up.
Uh,
maybe I'll put the ISB and on the screen
so you can look it up if you want.
Um,
but this one's good.
It's,
it has great texts.
The texts are interesting stories and
um,
and uh,
there's a lot of stories and there's,
there are some explanations of proverbs
and different expressions in Japanese.
Uh,
I found it really useful to just go
through the stories and highlight
vocabulary I didn't know,
and then look at the vocabulary lists
and the grammar exercises after,
after the stories.
I found it a bit hard to do all of the
exercises without a classroom teacher.
I did this on my own at home.
I've actually never taken the Japanese
lesson in my life and I did it all
through self study.
Um,
I found it a bit hard to do this all at
home self study style,
but I got through it and it was a bit of
hard work,
but I learned a lot from it.
So this one is good.
It's good material.
Just if you have a teacher it will be
easier for you cause they can help you
out with,
um,
with the exercises when the explanation
in Japanese is not quite clear.
All right,
so that was intermediate level.
At a more advanced level.
I used this one,
a Gq collagio cue and on your own goals.
So that's Japanese from the intermediate
level to the advanced level.
That's what that title means.
Um,
or as they say,
progressing from intermediate to
advanced,
that's uh,
that's the way they translated it.
So this one was pretty good.
Um,
it was kind of a bridge between
intermediate to advanced.
I got about halfway through this book
and it was good.
It was useful.
I learned a lot from it.
Uh,
but I started using authentic materials.
Instead I started just using newspapers
and,
and texts from magazines and just trying
to work through those and learn
vocabulary.
But this is good.
It's similar to the,
to the integrated approach to
intermediate Japanese won't like,
it has texts that are interesting and
then it breaks it down with the vocab
and the grammar exercises afterwards.
Um,
I found it quite similar in format and
just interesting to use,
but at that level I just thought it's
better to get into the authentic
materials.
Okay.
So those are the ones that I have used
and I think are pretty good and I
recommend,
I've used some others here and there.
Uh,
and I use some different ones for
Congee,
which I'll probably talk about in a
different video cause Kanji is a
different beast entirely and deserves
its own attention.
But I recommend all those,
especially this one,
which was my favorite integrated
approach to intermediate Japanese.
But if you're a beginner,
then you could get me not only Hong Kong
or you could get Japanese for busy
people and work through it.
One more note on Japanese for busy
people get the Kona version.
Don't get the romanized version.
There are to the romanized means it's
written in.
Well,
it has Roman characters in it and I
think it has the Japanese as well.
But,
um,
I don't recommend using the romanized
version because you might use the Roman
letters as a crutch.
It's good to get used to the corner
letters right away from the beginning.
Just dive right in.
You can learn them very quickly if you
dive in and make yourself do it.
So make yourself do it.
All right.
I hope that's helpful.
Have a nice night guys.
See Ya.
Okay.